about a dozen years ago a Philadelphia
Church thought athletics could be a form
of outreach to young people but they had
no idea how successful a effort would be
CBS News special correspondent Jane's
around paid them a visit and he joins us
now from our Washington bureau JV good
morning and good morning to you Michelle
and to Anthony and you know what the
growth of this church has mirrored the
sports program they've grown from 350
members in 94 to over 15,000 today and
enon Tabernacle Baptist Church offers
programs in several sports often with
multiple teams I visited the church
that's producing college and
professional athletes while achieving
its main goal of saving souls through
sports it's a hot saturday morning in
July and these kids at Northwest
Philadelphia are enjoying and working
hard at the sports they love and your
name we pray amen amen
good job let's get back to the game
fellas they are part of what enon
Tabernacle Baptist Church calls its
athletic ministry we like to say that we
are unapologetically youth oriented here
a teen on Reverend Allen Waller started
Ananse programs in 2005 as his church
was growing to its current size of
15,000 members I recognize sports as a
wonderful way to teach Christianity and
life through the medium of sports and
that's literally what our program is and
whether they go on to be great athletes
is not the real issue we want them to be
great people and that's what sports can
do but many have become great athletes
including three NFL players who attended
church at enon and many college athletes
like Heisman candidate University of
Georgia tailback DeAndre Swift who
started playing at enon when he was just
seven how surprised are you about how
successful it's been I'm not surprised
but I am excited about how extensive it
has become I'm excited to see the number
of children that are now going on to
college and so that's been wonderful
the program grew so big that in 2012
enon bought this 34 acre campus which
included the former football field for
Temple University the church spent
millions to build from the ground up
transforming a dirt pit into a
state-of-the-art church facility with
adjoining playing fields we probably
touch about a thousand kids a thousand
YoungStar thousand youngsters every year
with eight football teams for
cheerleading squads for baseball teams
track basketball soccer and martial arts
to manage the church took the rare step
of hiring a full-time athletic director
Greg Burris is a former church deacon
and retired business owner what I'm most
proud of here is just how we were able
to open it up to not just our membership
but to the community as well giving kids
an opportunity to come to come from
surrounding neighborhoods and and see us
and see parents on the sidelines
watching them and say this is the church
doing this in on sports camps are
subsidized by the church and cost a
fraction of other area programs that's a
big plus for parents like Keisha Bronson
and Monique elder whose children attend
church and play sports at Enon the
program here is enriching from a
spiritual perspective which was
important to me for my son's to be
around men who love the Lord as well as
love football and then some leaders out
front right guys if it please me and
only do they make it convenient but it's
all inclusive so you don't have to be a
member of the inner in church to be a
part of the program so you get exposure
to a lot of different children a lot of
different parents a lot of different
experiences but they're all in a very
safe and appropriate space camp
participants do not have to be church
members but pastor Waller says saving
souls is still the focus at enon you
don't have to belong you don't have to
believe what we believe but we have
things that we expect you to do if you
choose to play for our team such as well
we have mandatory Bible study we expect
you to participate in those Bible
studies we do have prayer but you know
this at the front end it's not
and switch you don't have to join the
church this is what we do and if you
want to play with us this is how we play
and the formula has worked anons teams
have won numerous local and regional
championships over the years with
talented kids like Colin Washington who
grew up playing at enon and is now a
scholarship football player at Temple
University we used to get choked on a
little bit helps across the church boys
when you're younger and then we wind up
winning but and then they'd be still
call us them what did this program do
for you just taught him sportsmanship
and how to treat people
coaches didn't curse here they Coast
cursed at other programs and they still
were able to get the best out of you
without profanity yes sir after playing
all day many parents and kids went right
across the street
for Saturday evening service for praise
and worship anon pastor Waller makes it
clear that the church's mission is
bigger than sports enon gives away a
total of four hundred thousand dollars
in college scholarships every year every
child that goes to school from this
church every year every semester gets
about two hundred fifty dollars from us
to just help them with some books or
encourage them midway through the
semester we're committed to athletics
were committed to academics we're
committed to raising and changing a
generation Waller is a third generation
preacher and he considers his work at
enon as part of a rich prophetic legacy
the photo in your office I can't help
but think that you represent what dr.
King Martin Luther King jr. was hoping
what happened in terms of that next
phase that picture of me sitting on
Martin King's lap has been with me since
the day it was taken he was preaching
for my father
in September of 67 he inspires me he
wanted to see the families come back
together he wanted us to really
participate in the greatest country on
the planet and even with all that's
going on I still believe that and like
him would like to fight to make sure
this country remains the great thing
that it is Michelle Alvina Patrick my
producer and I were very impressed with
how well rounded dr. Waller is as a
leader he's a chaplain to law
enforcement agencies locally and at the
federal level and he's not just a
visionary who was resting on his laurels
he recently completed a degree program
at the Harvard Business School to help
prepare him to be more strategic and
leading Enon into the next phase of
growth in success not only in North West
Philly but beyond
Anthony Michelle well beyond that that
begs the question where else what might
we see these programs you know every
time we hear dr. Waller talk he doesn't
talk about I it's always we so I
wouldn't be surprised to see other
programs around the country use that
medium as
our reach to impact folks as well and
Michelle to you and Dana's I
congratulate you guys being on the
Saturday show be mindful that when we
talk about sports Anthony is a one a
person who has burned out a few cycling
machine should beware if you invite you
to come join him okay that was a real I
want to say one thing back on your story
JB that was a very crowded Saturday
night sir yeah I noticed
we couldn't is impressive hey and anthe
that speaks to the growth of the church
and indeed their Saturday night services
are packed just like the two services on
Sunday all right coming to us from DC
today thanks JB